chez nous
salut à tous bienvenue à personne pour
vous parler d'une discipline qui compte
3000 licenciés 12 clubs huit disciplines
six sportifs qui évoluent sur le plan
national et pour nous en parler laurent
sigismeau et toi ta passion c'est quoi
laurent la gymnastique c'est parti
car l'amour gratuit
suit laurent est l'un des brevets d'état
en activité qui dynamise la gymnastique
à travers son club une association de
plus de 300 licenciés qui travaillent au
quotidien pour notre jeunesse
on va commencer l'échauffement vous
faites attention il ya les petits sur le
praticable alors on va courir contourner
les poutres et vous passez sous la fixe
ici c'est parti
la baby gym grosse partie des effectifs
de beaucoup de clubs représentent à midi
et nos licenciés dans l'île ce sport a
pour fondement le développement du petit
enfant
ça va permettre de comprendre d ordre d
instruction un désordre des inscriptions
à dire des consignes puis l'avion
communauté passe avant tout ce à quoi
je pense que ça les aide un peu et se
défoulent après l'école et c'est super
important poro
ça permet aux enfants d'écouter des
consignes et de les faire ce que c'est
pas évident pour des enfants d
premièrement de d'écouté ensuite de
réaliser un exercice donc des fois ils
sont en contrariété donc c'est trouver
toujours des petits petits outils pour
qu' il soit toujours dans le plaisir
parce que c'est un plaisir mais on
essaie de développer tout ce qu'il ya
une motrice et pour l'enfant ce que vous
êtes d'accord
après la mairie gilles ses lignes
acérées acrobatique y en a pour tous les
goûts sauf que pour la gymnastique
acrobatique fait du muscle donc moi
j'arrête
mister you were ses fils thomas
m
élastique acrobatique en fait c'est une
gymnastique qui fermait voilà de
retrouver les
les bases de la gymnastique danse des
éléments de la force il est maintien des
équipes par exemple on a les éléments de
l'acrobatie on a aussi des éléments
individuels donc des flips des saltos et
voilà